[Music]
in viral intentions news submitted by lo
mein oh I like lo mein
what is lo mean is that the egg noodle
or the rice noodle egg noodles also like
these shirts that you can just reach in
and scratch you've had it it's it's egg
noodle oh it's like yes but then like is
it bitter
it's like chow mein but it's not crispy
it's the it's the it's lower it sounds
it sounds like a very typical Asian
thing right we moved on here we go no I
had not a professor challenged his class
to go viral for an assignment that's
tight good luck what's the assignment
figure it out let me know
he went viral which is awesome ya know
so this class so this is a media
professor at Missouri State University
just re teaching a course called the
fundamentals of media convergence and
heat this course is a business based on
is it a business course it's the media I
don't know it sounds like a fun class
that was just classes like this when I
was in college
learn about media yeah try to make viral
ideas that's tight it was a different
game I call it marketing I was in
college in class I did so and that's
they were uh they were I found out about
YouTube through a sociology class
because they were talking about kind of
like how the internet was like
transforming like how people socialize
and you know you know it's so like I
found out about putting content on
YouTube through a sociology class I was
taking a sex tape if he put up a video
of Sean Dawson
Shane Dawson it could be an art class
like media arts film production yeah yes
it was a sociology course so so so he
said viral miss is the idea of making
something that draws an immediate mass
audience draws yeah and if you can do
that on purpose you're going to be a
rich person it's very difficult to do
and so his students came up with the
idea of this video it says my professor
threw a party instead of having a final
and no one showed up to your face and so
this is a video and then people are
crying reacting to it like it just went
crazy it's fake as [ __ ] right yeah it
was part of the assignment but people
don't know that I'm naturally obviously
so we really went viral do in viral like
oh yeah it has 70,000 retweets and three
hundred and forty four thousand likes
oh that's that's a Twitter viral yeah
that's really good that's crazy yeah so
this is the professor I want him to be
my uncle now why uncle because he looks
like a really cool uncle better give you
positivity when your parents like a
director yeah that's what I'm gonna say
like Steven Spielberg his brother or
some [ __ ] yeah if he would have said
father there would have been a couple of
weird things with that yeah I just
wanted to it could have been like my god
this father or like a yeah well I'm but
I'm also Asian and he's white so it
makes sense for him to be my uncle than
my dad he could be your stepdad
yeah I didn't think about stepfathers
but then I also like connotates this
particular type of inconvenience and
connotates like what sounds like a
delicious Tater Tot like I hate to hear
your sex talk dude that wasn't even sex
pop that was food talk you said you
could turn anything into a food unique
oddly shaped I love them you ready for
this bratwurst oh man anyway what about
yeah this a lot of people are just
really disappointed to find out that it
was fake they felt disappointed it felt
so do a lot of stuff oh yeah yeah yeah
there's so many set of viral things that
you see the classic what's it called the
two couples fighting and then the girl
like is supposed to
it was imitating the viral video of this
guy in a girl fighting but it was
obviously a Latina woman and she's like
[ __ ] calling up [ __ ] and a [ __ ]
screaming on the parking lot guys like
recording from a building and afterwards
like five minutes later she just arts
kissing him oh yeah yeah so they were
trying to imitate that viral video and
another thing but they set it up as fake
but they obviously didn't want people
know it's fake but it was so [ __ ]
fake because the guy was really close
and she's supposed to be screaming but
she's making no noise coming out her
mouth so you can hear the pups like
banging but you can't exactly but
everyone's like what the [ __ ] how come
you could hear the cups like but you
can't hear their voices that's [ __ ]
dumb the other one I remember I forgot
what attention which night show did this
one with Jimmy Kimmel I think so with
the twerk
yeah that's working girl the upside-down
twerk and then she falls on the glass
table and then everything sets on fire
that one was fake oh yeah so like it was
genius though because like that went
viral and then like later on there the
the clip extends so I think I was shared
right was likes like her roommate or
whatever like opens the door wall she's
like on a handstand doing its work she
falls over on some candles and stuff
everything lights on fire but then like
in the extended video it's like he shows
the original and then like the roommate
walks in or something like oh the door
opens I think Jimmy Kimmel is the one
who actually comes in and he's got like
a fire extinguisher and the whole
thing's plants it was like man this is
[ __ ] genius yeah we're like Bieber
he's eating a hotdog and then he eats it
like if this is a hotdog he bites it
this way instead of going this way and
then people were going [ __ ] wild that
Bieber was doing this but it was like a
look-alike that's awful even like that
so there's some things that people do
they're so basic that bothers people
like if you see somebody you're hot by
like that it's like or somebody cuts a
cake and they [ __ ] just you know they
[ __ ] it all up or some [ __ ] like that
that bothers me so much instead of going
all the way through to go it cut a
little odd triangle out of it I'm like
what the [ __ ] would you do that you son
of a [ __ ] I'm gonna start eating tacos
like this like this or you trying to eat
it we're standing up this way you go
I forgot your name a lot of people are
just like what it was viral cuz it even
got to a point where Missouri State
their Twitter account like Reese I quote
tweeted it where it says faculty members
here care about you a lot hashtag gold
maroon so did they get out a on that
project they did oh-o-oh because it was
a plan of five student project but it's
interesting too cuz I don't know if
there's a life lesson than that but it
is too it's just people just want to
believe anything that they see well yeah
I mean the thing that the professor
saying is to like everyone needs to be
more weight aware luscious of what
they're watching me internet and what
they believe in cuz I he was like how
come no one questioned that a professor
didn't give out a final like why was
that like oh yeah that's common I think
it is common actually have you guys I
don't think I had it at a stupa at a
collegiate level oh that's true
community college level is the dilemma
you guys see Facebook de la no what is
that oh [ __ ]
okay um not to go too deep in the rabbit
hole but like PBS like put out this like
special so it's like legit twenty-eight
PBS that's the Sesame Street channel
love PBS yeah so they put this dude it
was like online yeah the dudes face
right and it was called Facebook dilemma
and it was pretty much following really
what happened with Facebook and the the
privacy issues that they had yeah it's a
like third party oh yeah will not use
that data and then how the Russians
specifically had like different kind of
internet hubs that like use virality
against people to like brainwash the
prop again yes well so like through
Facebook most people were getting their
information on like how they were going
to vote or like what they thought their
peers were thinking or what types of
articles were like kind of scanning out
and naturally based off the way that
human beings are we [ __ ] for some
reason are so interested by like bad
[ __ ] right anything that has like a a
thousand comments on the thread or like
some sort of crazy headline
just blows your mind right
algorithmically if you will if the more
things that are like that the more they
pop up in your newsfeed we've been doing
that but but the thing is with Facebook
is that they they're not a verified or
trusted news source
maybe CNN could be maybe you like you
know a Fox News even those you know
whatever could be technically too so
you'll have these types of articles on
Facebook so you accept that Facebook is
giving you real news but then there's
also random [ __ ] that people will just
put there that kind of like really
diversify our or are really kind of like
increased attention and the extremity
between like you know the Republicans in
the Democrats in America because they
were putting the very extremist
perspectives or videos or clips or think
and it's all fake but because it would
like go like viral if you will
algorithmically it would end up on more
people's feeds so it started increasing
by propaganda like the the the distance
between like our political you we we've
talked about that situate we have to
read all that should we just see it from
our platform right and so I had to
explain that to a relative of mine
because he's so gullible about
everything he reads on Facebook
I actually I mean I had a column I
didn't like just [ __ ] out him out on
Facebook and I don't go on Facebook that
often but every time I read his stuff it
was so [ __ ] negative it was always
about politics it was based on all these
like random like clips that he would see
he goes do you see this is what Dems are
[ __ ] liberal little [ __ ] they need to
go on Snopes yeah and so like I
literally had a call man a conversation
with them was like hey man you have to
realize right now whatever you're seeing
on your feet in the state that you live
in versus the state that I live in I
have an article that will debunk
everything that you say and you have to
be an article that they fund everything
that'll I bet that I will say I'll say
based on what you see the stuff that you
like the stuff that you enjoy you're
gonna get fed that I was like I
guarantee you what you say is facts
right now I have an article that they're
pushing to me on Facebook because I'm in
the more of a blue area it's going to
say that your stuff is trashed I was
like every time you do that you look
like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah I mean you're becoming that old guy
that's just sitting there like oh no
wonder the country's like this and it's
that same [ __ ] thing is because and I
told him this screen cap I was like I
want you to screen cap all the stuff
that you said to me that you have
beginnings doing that he just kind of
wrote wrote to me like what it was later
through Facebook and I was like see and
I just send him some other stuff I was
like this article debunking you say
right here so which was true he got an
article from the onion or something it's
like it's like yellow and black but they
kind of like yeah yeah out like
certainly things that Trump say I think
it's also hard to because even legit
news sources like CNN is getting caught
for a lot of weird like I saw this one
video where there were Trump supporters
that that that that weren't Trump that
they decided to denounce Trump right and
then man the internet so [ __ ] crazy
what they got was a bunch of guys that
were training that they used to be Trump
supporters and stuff like that and then
they did some research on the actors and
they were like always pro demo like they
always had they had channels that were
all about liberal activism and all that
prior to them claiming that they were
Trump supporters so they pretended that
they were Trump supporters to be on this
like panel and talk about how they
changed in and then all propaganda it's
[ __ ] crazy now that's what I I think
it's like everything's kind of fake news
for sure no I don't know what's yeah or
not cuz like yeah statistics well get
look at this song there's an angle
there's an angle for everything sir
saying here's your final you gotta go
make something viral whereas like
they're like a third-world country type
of like lookin areas you know I mean
we're like kids will write headline news
on things and if their link or their
whatever becomes viral the more clicks
they get the more they get paid so
people are like sitting down somewhere
in the world right now and in their
minds they're like for some reason
anytime we mentioned like America Trump
did this thing nuclear blah blah
North Korea it's like that's gonna get a
lot of trashes so people are just making
[ __ ] up for the sake of making money and
a lot of people - they'll feel like in
this in this country or maybe everybody
in their country they I feel like the
people that I'm seeing right now they're
not thinking really globally so it's in
terms of this like the stuff that you
guys put out i I hate the fact that this
stupid and American are synonymous now
stupid American stupid American stupid
American you know and that's like how
other people are viewing this kind
which is so weird to me like I hate that
fact and you know and I think we're
pretty stupid though
even we in this channel we could dress
like but it's it's it's because we're so
we're not taught a lot of things like
growing up like and our education is not
standardized like someone that's going a
Gardena high school like it's gonna be
different from Beverly Hills High School
it's not it's not completely true all
across the board its regional - I don't
know man like the the literacy rate in
like China or whatever it's like pretty
high maybe it's because I see America as
like as an innovator and a lot of things
you know a lot of people emulate this
country we are innovators we are
innovators but we also I think people
also don't know like with population
comes higher numbers of worse [ __ ] -
right like if we have a lot of people
we're also gonna have a lot of losers
yeah and you know a lot of like [ __ ]
and and it's like other countries like
Canada Australia their population isn't
as big they're like as big as one of our
states so of course they're gonna have
less [ __ ] less whatever I think it's
also - it might even play in the fact of
like you know how smaller people the
smaller countries have more pride in
their country yeah I mean it's just a
lot less people exactly you know in like
America is so vast yeah people from
California the people from New York
exactly yeah yep
so it's just a population thing so I
guess just in terms of life lesson that
we were talking about and like the
changes that we went on yeah don't
[ __ ] believe anything that's viral
just because like millions of people
have seen it or like thousands of people
have commented because it's all big ass
[ __ ] out there no like that one homeless
dude that it's been his last $20 for gas
and it turned out that they are all in
on it to scam people from donating yeah
that's pretty
Russian value an Asian dude